johnny the person who just who explained
to me what homosexuality was
while appearing on andy cohen's sirius
xm radio andy to promote the new season
of yellowjackets actress christina ricci
shares how johnny depp taught her the
concept of homosexuality at the age of
nine while shooting the 1990 film
mermaids alongside cher and winona ryder
ricci reveals that a moment on set
sparked her to ask ryder who is dating
depp at the time what homosexuality is
there was something going on on set and
someone was not being nice to someone
else and they were like oh well he might
be
homophobic and then
uh i was like well i don't understand
what that is and and i was in winona's
trailer and she was like i don't know
how
she put me on the phone with johnny and
johnny explained it to me okay imagine
having johnny depp be the person to
explain what homosexuality is to you
talk about quite the conversation
however christina explains that depth
kept it very factual and straight to the
point that her nine-year-old self
quickly understood like it's when a man
wants to have sex with a man and when a
woman wants to have sex with a woman and
i was like i mean okay
now andy quickly chimed in at just how
funny it was that winona passed the
responsibility to johnny when there was
a very prominent and iconic queer ally
over in the next trailer i love it that
winona ryder had to put you on the phone
with johnny depp to get that story that
she couldn't spit it out in some way or
i mean you've got cher in the next
trailer i know we should have run right
over there while learning from cher
would have been very cool cher told
entertainment tonight at the 1990s
mermaid premiere that ricci had taught
her a lot which it seems the
nine-year-old star had no memory of we
interviewed cheer the other day and she
said you taught her a lot of stuff what
did you teach sharon
i don't know
hey thanks for watching et canada if you
want more queer entertainment news and
exclusive interviews be sure to
subscribe and check out these videos